my mom was gonna lose her house
i didn't really know what was going on
to be honest and i didn't care i want to
be successful on the field i actually
made a million dollars i was like i
can't spend any of this you're gonna
walk into the restaurant with a bag of
cash
this is the reunion where former college
athletes meet up 10 years later to talk
lessons learned about sports money and
life
[Music]
all right happy 10-year reunion okay
tori smith jake locker both in the 2011
draft class it's now 2021. if you could
give me one word to describe your
journey what where would you use
a struggle i'm the oldest of seven so
i've always been used to having
responsibility you know financially even
coming from a background where i didn't
have much the reason why i left school
early
i'm at a family issue and my
mom was gonna lose her house
and if i didn't have money by a certain
point because we knew she wasn't going
to have it i was trying to help my
family in that situation complicated i
think would be for mine because i felt
all the same things as heavy at times
learning to uh
balance
these changing responsibilities really
my wife and and and my child and these
things almost at times seemed to feel
like they were in conflict with these
other responsibilities that i came into
the league seeing and understanding
we've both been retired for a few years
now and our some of our peers are still
going strong but i think it's about our
lives and what's transpired since then i
probably sit here
more so now than i did 10 years ago
looking at myself through it through the
lens of
what it what it means to be a man within
your community within your home
all right so let's take a stroll down
memory lane we've got some high-res
highlights yeah look at this
looks like playing in the 90s yeah
that's right it makes you feel really
old
you definitely see the baby face too my
lock's hanging out the back it's right
it definitely reminds me of the younger
version of myself
describe what it's like to become a
millionaire uh pretty much overnight
yeah for me i was dropped in the second
round so i wasn't a millionaire quite
overnight but i had a little bit of
change for a 22 year old and
i had zero financial literacy yeah right
i grew up in a family where
it was check to check but the reality of
it is we were in a situation where i had
to support so i was kind of balancing
really i need to support and i needed
help but also i can't lose what i have
and go broke because we've seen a lot of
examples of that did you have some
semblance of financial literacy i hired
a financial advisor and i didn't really
know what was going on to be honest and
i didn't i didn't ask i didn't care it
didn't seem to matter to me and i want
to be successful in the field well i
think it's important to talk about
financial literacy in general yeah right
like why is it that you and i didn't
have an understanding of what we were
walking into so i think we can really
learn from it especially now continuing
to share our journeys and that's one
thing i learned in the locker room there
are a lot of guys who made some mistakes
but they're also a lot of guys who've
done things the right way too and but
you don't know unless you talk about it
and that financial journey is something
that people don't talk about enough how
has your definition of rich
changed
throughout time man i remember thinking
a million dollars was like the most
money in the world i remember being a
kid thinking if i had a million dollars
i'd do both x y and z
and then i actually made a million
dollars i was like i can't spend any of
this if i want to make it last right
when you understand that that you know
that's a resource
um that is not that not only allows you
um
some opportunities but people around you
as well and you see it as a resource
that's yours to steward rather than
uh yours to hoard i think then then
there's freedom in that then it becomes
a gift and there's actually a joy in
your relation to your money um
and and that's that's how i that's how i
felt i remember one time i
bought some jewelry and i took it back
you took back the jewelry i took it back
i was like
i paid probably
i want to say maybe around like 20 000
for it what a chain necklace yeah it was
a chain little neck
maybe a little bit more maybe even
closer to 30 right
and then i was just sitting there and i
didn't wear it i'll tell you a real
quick funny story but i was i was you
know drafted as a quarterback and so the
linemen you know go out and do a
dinner every year
uh every week and so one week they i've
been told it's my week to pay and called
my wife and i'm like honey i need you to
go to the bank and i need you to take
out 15 000 in cash
and she's like for what i'm like i gotta
pay for this dinner yeah our cards don't
have a big enough limit to do it so i
need cash and she's like you just want
me to bring a bag of cash yeah it's like
yeah just drop it off at the farm i've
told them and then she's like you're
gonna walk into the restaurant with a
bag of cash jake and i'm like yeah i
don't know what else to do she's like i
can bring the checkbook and i'm like
okay i guess that would work like what
are we this is crazy but uh yeah
when you look at these i mean what do
you just think about your college career
i feel like college is better than the
league in some ways just simply because
of its innocence you know you transition
on and out it's really business you know
back then it was pure think about all
the memories and and
just the wonderful opportunity to create
relationships
you know you decided to retire at the
age of 26.
i think at that time mental health was
not something that was discussed the way
that it is now yeah but when you look
back on it is that what you maybe would
have labeled uh what you were feeling in
that moment i think
if i'm being honest you know felt like a
responsibility to the organization to
the teammates to that city um and i felt
all of that and i felt like it wasn't a
place that you really could be honest
about those things because you'd be
criticized for that you would be soft
you would be
mentally weak and and so i
i agree that
that needs to change because i think
there's i think all of us deal with that
in different ways i'm comfortable saying
that some of my darkest days existed
while i was playing right being thinking
that money was gonna solve problems it
didn't
right thinking that being living this
dream was gonna be the greatest thing
ever it wasn't all the time what word do
you want to describe
the next 10 years
of your life fruitfulness
um
just i think being faithful with what
you have and and trusting that
as you put your heart into things
there's fruitfulness from that for the
lives of others
i'd say purpose
you know
fully living out what i was called to do
um making sure that i'm able to help
others learn from my mistakes i don't
feel like my mistakes were for me right
they were they happened to me and it's
important for me to make sure that the
next person young man young woman
doesn't make those exact same mistakes
but also simply just do what i was
called to do along with my family right
trying to be the example uh continue to
be the the leader of my household i'm
supposed to be and continue to grow more
as a man
i love that one ten years
i'm gonna call and check on and make
sure those words uh lived up lived up to
it as we look to the future no this was
amazing thank you guys so much for being
so open and honest and we appreciate
your time
[Music]
you